this is an extra video to show you how
these devices here can demonstrate the
kelvin helmholtz effect
dr barbara turnbull is running the
experiment and she's much better at
explaining everything but wasn't wearing
a microphone during the experiment here
so i'm afraid you're stuck with me
mainly
there are two devices simply because we
ran the experiment twice always good to
have a back up
the first step is pumping the tanks half
full
or half empty depending on your
viewpoint with fresh water
we left the fresh water clear here in
tank 1 but in tank 2 the fresh water's
dyed red just for ease of viewing
lovely
[Music]
then we create salt water pretty simple
that
and in both cases the salt water's dyed
blue again just so we can see it better
with the tanks still tipped upright the
salt water is very gradually pumped in
from below it mustn't mix with the less
dense fresh water sitting above it
so you can see the fresh water stays on
top
[Music]
when it's full to the brim it's a fiddly
process to then seal the tanks making
sure there are no air bubbles inside
next and this is done very carefully in
incremental steps the tanks are tipped
to the horizontal
[Music]
crucial the layers don't mix and in both
cases we now have the denser salt water
below the fresh water when the layers
have settled everything's calm the
apparatus is tipped
now the salt water is flowing that way
and the fresh water that way
and there's our effect in tank one
[Music]
here are some more camera angles
[Music]
[Music]
and of course slow motion
[Music]
and then as promised we did it again in
tank two
[Music]
and of course there it is again
[Music]
i think this is amazing look how
impressed these guys are
[Music]
and just in case you're wondering we
measured the salt water just to check
its density so there you go and if
you're wondering why these tanks are
even here well the university of
nottingham students do this experiment
as part of their studies
as you can see
thanks again to dr turnable and to see
our main video on the kelvin helmholtz
effect you can click the links on screen
or in the video description over the top
of this bump here is actually traveling
faster than the
material below
and if you want to watch more videos
well you know we've always got them
thanks for watching 60 symbols we always
appreciate having you here kind of a
subtlety here that you probably don't
actually want to sit absolutely at the
lagrange point for example one real
disadvantage of being right at the l2
point if you think about it if you had a
satellite here